if you allow politicians to to conduct
themselves in this way and to
delegitimize the democratic process
which both
sides have done uh but particularly in
my opinion the the democrats in america
and the left in this country as well
then what you end up with is a situation
where we are now where 36
of both democrats and republicans feel
uh that violence is justified to achieve
your political ends so a third of both
supporter groups are quite happy to use
violence which has gone up from eight
percent about two years ago
so if you've got that situation the
election is in dispute both parties are
undermining the democratic process
and encouraging their followers
essentially to feel like violence is a
way of resolving this issue
not a good recipe
the stakes have been raised now haven't
they based on the darren grimes incident
i'm now
culpable for what you say so please
go gently on me or i'm gonna be in
prison and you'll be in a gulag
well i'm gonna struggle to say anything
now and i
i apparently am so ridiculously
controversial with my
very mainstream opinions that uh yeah
we're both in trouble
if we sit in silence for the next hour
that is one surefire way that we can't
get in trouble
that could offend people who really
wanted to listen to us talk though and
they might report us to the police and
uh
yeah you never know man but if you
remember you came to see my show in
edinburgh last year
and this is exactly what i was talking
about should it be illegal
to have offensive opinions and here we
are
and essentially the police are
investigating people not even for their
own opinions for stuff someone else said
on their show that they broadcast
um and you know you add to that the
response
to the pandemic and how that's affecting
our civil liberties as well
uh it's not a great time no not at all
so can you give us a brief overview and
take us through what we've learned from
the darren grimes situation
in your opinion well so for people who
don't know darren grimes is a
conservative right-wing commentator he i
think
is rather hated by uh many people
on my side of the referendum debate
people who voted romaine
as i did a lot of people who are sort of
very
uh obsessed with that issue in a way
that i'm not
i felt that because he was part of the
campaign to make that happen
he was investigated three times by the
electoral commission for his involvement
and that
uh so he's got a lot of enemies i think
that's part of it for sure
uh but basically he had dr david starkey
controversial historian who made some
what i thought were ill-judged comments
and
i know david we've had him on the show
he didn't say anything like that on our
show
uh but on darren's he did make some uh
controversial comments
which i as i say i thought we were ill
judged um
and this happened a few months ago there
was a big ferrari dr david starkey was
properly cancelled for it
um he apologized eventually darren
apologized for
for not challenging him on what he said
and that was
sort of the end of the matter uh i think
a lot of people felt that
even though i think many people felt
that
he it was appropriate that david starkey
suffered some consequences for what he
said uh equally many people felt that
maybe the consequences were
quite harsh uh wherever you sit on that
i respect both views on that personally
um and that was sort of the end of the
matter for most people i think
until we found out last week as we
record this
that the police had invited initially we
learned that it was darren
grimes and then also then david starkey
had both been invited for what is
euphemistically called
a voluntary interview uh interesting
it's called that because if you don't
attend you get arrested
the voluntary nature of that interview
is a little bit interesting
um and uh yeah so essentially
we're talking about the police
investigating people for things that
they say
and for the interviewers for things that
their
guests say uh we we had darren grimes on
the show
pretty much straight away because we
felt it was a very important issue to
raise to the public awareness
there were lots of other mainstream
media coverage as well
and hopefully as a result of all of that
publicity that that happened
uh the police said that they've got a
senior
uh officer reviewing the case they've
postponed the interviews that they were
supposed to have
and at the time actually everyone from
asaka all the way through to pretty
patel and sajid javid and many many
other people
who at the time felt that david
starkey's comments were completely wrong
some of them said they were horrible
racist etc even those people
were saying aren't the police going too
far here
and so as a result it seems that the
police have rode back they've realized
there's a public backlash
uh how that ends we don't know because
they haven't closed the investigation
uh yeah but but it it's it's a troubling
thing because
uh i would imag and it's what i find
really surprising about this and i'm not
again one of these sort of
defunder bbc people uh but i do think
the bbc is biased
and what i found fascinating was they
didn't cover the story on their
mainstream news at all
so while he was being talked about in
the telegraph
in the times it was on the front page of
the times i think at least on the online
version
the bbc simply pretended it wasn't
happening which i thought was very
interesting why do you think that's
happening
i i don't know exactly but i felt for
some time now
the the bbc are not reporting on
cultural issues objectively whether
you you know the economy or all that
sort of thing there's more of a
conversation to be had about
which way they lean some people might
even argue that they lean to the right
on those things
but certainly when it comes to people
like darren who as i say are hated by
many people on the remain
side and many people on the left as well
uh i don't think he he got a fair shake
at it if you remember
you know a couple of years ago when i
turned down that safe space contract
uh that was in every newspaper in the
country and the bbc covered it very
prominently
it was right up there and that was an
issue that many people felt had a lot to
do with free speech
well to me this isn't an issue of darren
uh
being conservative or not or whatever i
don't uh share many of his views
the point is something like that is an
issue that everyone should care about
because if you're a bbc journalist well
you know the bbc has had people like
tommy robinson and katie hopkins on
their show people that i would not have
on my show
right on trigonometry we wouldn't have
them on so
you know they are more liable to that
sort of problem than we are in a way and
yet they're not saying anything about it
and i think it speaks to some kind of
bias now what exactly that is i don't
know
uh i've been on the bbc many many times
and my perception of it is that it's
it's full of well-meaning people
uh who all think the same so no matter
how how hard they try and i think a lot
of people genuinely do try on their bbc
to introduce balance but if everyone in
your organization thinks
the same way on these cultural issues of
the culture war
then it's very difficult to then present
a balanced view
of an issue and with the news coverage
of darren grimes i think they just
you know they genuinely just like
basically
he suppressed it yeah man i mean
when i first delved into the situation
i'd missed
the original david starkey interview so
i had to track back and kind of
get a grasp on everything in real time
um
but man i'm really really concerned
i would have been concerned had this
backtracking by the police not occurred
the ability or the the um potential for
me
as an independent podcaster doing it's a
lovely bedroom but doing it from his
bedroom
um the potential that i could have
anyone
on i've spoken to porn stars i've spoken
to the
girl who started the uk version of only
fans i've spoken to douglas murray like
all the same thing obviously
and um like you know how to pick your
guests man you go for the top
i really just go for the creme de la
creme yeah filtering
we should reconsider we talk to all
these boring political analysts and
stuff like that you've gone straight in
there with the best
browsers that's who the top 10 on
browsers that's who you need to speak to
um so i've got these people on they
could say anything and somehow
i would be liable for what they say
now i'm going to guess that the only
potential justification for this would
be
to treat an independent podcaster like
darren is like
you guys are like i am as a broadcaster
as if we're
as if we have some sort of network in
the traditional media sense of the word
that we are broadcasting
media and therefore we are liable for
what occurs on our channel
is that if you were to um steel man the
argument do you think that's kind of
where it comes from
yeah i think that's exactly where it
comes from and look we're all dealing
with a new world
in which all of this stuff is unusual i
mean
podcasts have only been around 10-15
years and so our laws
probably not all that well adjusted to
to the whole situation so i i think
uh you know obviously big media
corporations they have whole legal
departments that deal with these that
train the presenters
you know what you can and can't allow
guests to say what can and can't go
unchallenged
even there there's quite a lot of bias
in how all of that's treated
so it's perfectly possible i mean you
talk about douglas murray
one of the most prominent conservative
commentators in the country
uh and maybe you know a lot of the stuff
he's been talking about lately you
wouldn't even
say that it's a conservative view
particularly but it's perfectly normal
for him to go on the bbc
and be called far right by a fellow
guest
without necessarily being challenged
that guest being challenged
in the moment he then has to threaten to
sue they then apologize
right whereas if if you'd gone and and
slandered somebody from the other side
you wouldn't be the same so for someone
like me who's bang in the center of
politics
those hypocrisies are very difficult to
ignore because they're just right there
staring you
in the face um but but yeah i think the
steel man version of the argument is
we're broadcasting stuff to an
unspecified number of people and that
means we're subject to broadcasting
regulation and that means that
we are responsible to some extent for
what people say uh
having said that there is a difference
between television and
a podcast because television or radio
that is broadcast into an
unspecified number of people who may or
may not have opted in
for that particular content right so if
you've just got the radio playing in the
background and then someone comes on and
starts
as in david starkey's case talking about
damn blacks or something like that
you know there's that's that's different
to you clicking on a podcast which is
clearly discussing you know the history
of slavery let's say and then being
triggered
that that's happened so there is a there
is a difference to be had but i'm not
you know i i don't necessarily think i
have the answer
particularly because should we be able
to just have anyone on to say whatever
they want
without any repercussions whatsoever
probably not
you know there is some responsibility i
mean we are subject to the laws of the
land if you have someone on who
you know incites violence well i don't
think that should be exempt
simply because you're doing it from your
bedroom right so there's there's a way
to calibrate it
but i think holding us to exactly the
same standard as the bbc or itv i think
that that's taking it a bit far so
i guess we'll wait and see what what
what what our
legislative bodies come up with yeah for
sure
both you just now and during the
discourse i heard
this week with darren as well one of the
things that he said in his defense is
um i was basically starstruck by david
starkey stark struck
and i didn't challenge his
views as i should have done does that
make any difference
like does it make any difference about
whether or not you decide to challenge
someone's views the views are out there
in the ether based on your broadcast i'm
not sure
what my position is about whether or not
him saying hang on a second david you
can't really say that
like does that change what he said
in its essence well
i i don't i'm not a lawyer so i don't
know the law on that that seems to
certainly be the mainstream approach
right if you get someone controversial
on you don't let them talk
that's that's how they do it right so
so maybe that's what exempts you from
being associated
then with those views maybe people
assume uh that
you know if you let me talk that means
you agree with everything i'm saying
silence is compliance well yeah there
was during this whole
episode recently people said that
silence is consent which i thought was
quite interesting given
uh the me too stuff we've had before i
mean
[Laughter]
with that argument i just thought that
was an interesting linguistic quirk if
anything
and it sort of shows how ridiculous it
is you know uh my our friend
lou perez uh from uh we the internet who
we had on the show a few months ago
uh you know he posted at the time of the
blm riots that were happening he said
silence violence right uh
speech is violence but actual violence
is not violence when people were saying
these are peaceful you know
uh so that's where we are but i think
yeah i think because we are used to the
mainstream
media format of interviewing people
which is you get someone on for a
maximum of 10 minutes
and the moment they say anything that is
in any way perceived as controversial
you have to jump in
and offer a counter argument then maybe
when you see someone
like us having a conversation uh then
people assume that because you haven't
interrupted me you've agreed with every
single word that i've said
and therefore that lack of challenge is
perceived as endorsement
yeah yeah you are right the the
paradigms are shifting
i got an email so i got such an
interesting email man on the day
that the darren grimes story uh broke
hey there i'm matt the founder of
influencer protect
i specialize in helping podcasters with
all their insurance needs
i offer a bespoke service to help
support areas such as
making an untrue statement that results
in reputational damage
breaching and advertising ruling
unintentionally copyright infringement a
brand making a claim against you blah
blah blah blah blah blah
am i hang on am i going to have to buy
insurance to be a podcaster now
like this is obviously an emerging
market i think it was um
coincidence rather than a
entrepreneurial foresight
that he got that particular email but
like man it really is i'll be very very
interested i got a dm off darren earlier
on today for anyone who's interested
today is the day the morning of this
friday the 16th of october was when
darren was supposed to be in
the police station for the voluntary not
voluntary interview
and he sent me an update over his the
email dear mr grahams were
um writing to inform you that the senior
officer has been appointed to conduct a
review of this matter and ensure that it
remains proportionate
and the all-appropriate lines of inquiry
are being considered
while this review takes place please
note that this time you are no longer
required to attend kingston police
station we'll contact you in due course
with further updates i mean that's what
happens when you marshal the forces of
darkness
which was absolutely happening but yeah
man i um
it's worrying that's you know previously
the the count dankula stuff i appreciate
that there are this sort of
death by a thousand cuts situation going
on i was
able to distance myself from that and
feel quite detached because i'm like
unlikely that i would be in the
situation where that occurs but
you know darren is slap bang in my
wheelhouse uh and he's a northern lad as
well so yeah that that really that sort
of shook me a little bit considering how
much i care about this project
that was that was uncomfortable to find
out i know what you mean
about dankeller and of course he's not
the only person that this has happened
to we can go down the list
harry miller who who retweeted a
supposedly transphobic
poem of some kind on twitter gets a call
from the police saying we need to check
your thinking
right that's happened posey parker again
a
gender-critical uh former feminist she
was interviewed by the police for
expressing some of her views on trans
issues
um chelsea russell who i talked about in
my in my show last year
uh the the girl from i think she was
from liverpool uh she
she posted the lyrics of a song on her
instagram in tribute to a friend of hers
who'd been killed in a car crash
and it was a rap song so it contained
the n-word and she was actually
prosecuted and convicted
for uh whatever it would have been
offensive language or something like
that
eventually got overturned an appeal so
we're seeing a lot of these cases coming
through
in the pipeline and what it essentially
means is
yes of course i understand your feeling
of like well look dankilla didn't really
affect me whereas darren is more in my
wheelhouse
but the reality of all of this stuff is
none of us can afford
to only look at our own situation on
this issue you know it's like it's a bit
like saying
you know would you approve of summary
execution for people who
commit certain offenses well you you
might never commit that particular
offence
but that doesn't mean you would
necessarily approve of people being you
know pulled up on the street
lined up against the wall and it's the
same with the free speech issue
uh yes a lot of people weren't on board
with dankula
they didn't think his his sketch or
whatever it was was funny
uh but that doesn't necessarily mean
that he should have been convicted of
hate speech or find
800 pounds or or and and be a hate
criminal for life which is essentially
where he's
he is now so i think you principles
like this always require you to defend
people that you don't agree with and
don't like
and that's just an inevitability uh most
people prefer to just stick to the
comfortable which is well
i like this guy therefore i'll defend
him but actually none of us can afford
to do that
yeah a principle isn't a principle until
it costs you
moving on moving on from the darren
grimes situation
uh what unique insight has your cultural
habit heritage giving you
when looking at the world in 2020 have
you got some
particularly interesting insights based
on where you're from
um well i grew up in russia in the 90s
immediately uh during and after well
before as well but
before during and after the collapse of
the soviet union so i saw
a very stable society where everything
was going smoothly
very predictable everybody went to work
for nine o'clock left work at five
o'clock went home
made food spend time with the children
everything was very stable very
consistent very predictable
to overnight society being transformed
into something completely different and
largely unrecognizable
people who up to that point were very
successful
wealthy they had a good income they had
a predictable future they had a solid
career ahead of them
suddenly for some people that that just
disappeared overnight
and equally there was lots of
opportunity for other people who had
you know new ideas or in as in the
russian case we're just prepared to be
immoral
or whatever it was all the opportunities
in between
um to build something new and i think
what we're seeing now
with the coronavirus and the response to
it and how our countries are dealing
with it
is much less shocking to me and also my
co-host from trigonometry francis who's
who's a family are from venezuela
where he's seen something very similar
you know we are not really shocked or
particularly troubled by this situation
in the same way because we're like
well yeah this is you know this idea
that everything was always going to
continue
in the same way and be stable and
predictable and uncomfortable
um that's that's never going to be true
over the long term
these shocks will always happen so for
me
that background of growing up in a very
unstable environment that literally
flipped overnight
uh it gives me an insight into into
what's gonna happen now and you know i
feel
desperately sad for a lot of people
whose lives have been thrown up into
complete chaos
many people losing work jobs security
you know and and it's going to run and
run because the economic impact of
what's happened hasn't even been felt
yet
we're probably going to have the biggest
recession we've had for for centuries
well that's the thing we've got the pain
now in the immediate but it's our
children who are going to pay the
financial burden with
either inflation interest rates whatever
way that the governments decide to try
and recuperate
all of this expenditure it's all well
and good people having parties in the
street because rishi's going to throw 8
billion at you
but that 8 billion needs repaying some
at some point sure and the 8 billion is
a tiny fraction of what we're really
talking about
uh there was a story in the times
yesterday about the people who are
designing this government app for track
and trace
uh doing it mainly on excel as we now
know uh they're getting paid about seven
and a half grand a day
so they are basically on premier league
footballer wages
to make the shitty app that doesn't work
uh and that the total cost of that is
about 12 billion pounds
just for that so we're basically
throwing
uh bad money after bad money after bad
money uh at this whole problem
and i think your analysis is somewhat
optimistic you say it's our children
they're gonna pay for this no no
it's gonna be us first we're gonna
right and then their children are going
to pay for it too
um so i but but equally
as i say uh a time of crisis is also a
time of opportunity the people who are
just and adapt
and learn from this and understand
that you know the traditional way of
doing things isn't going to work
and respond to that with ingenuity and
creativity
they will benefit tremendously too uh
and so
my background i think gives me the
understanding that this [ __ ] happens
this [ __ ] always happens and you gotta
be ready to to adjust and move with the
time so for us for example
you know trigonometry used to be a one
episode a week
uh show uh and we might do a live stream
once a week as well
when the lockdown hit we were like well
we're two comedians who don't
have a stage to perform on anymore let's
do more interviews
let's do more live streams so we are now
broadcasting a piece of content and now
long
every day except monday right so we've
ramped that up and our fans have have
responded we've got
we've grown our audience massively the
support for the show has
been great as well although we're
starting to see it you know it's
starting to dip now as people struggle
with
with
you know with what we're talking about
with the economy people are losing jobs
you know somebody who who was supporting
us at quite high level giving us
50 quid 100 quid a month uh those people
who you'd think well
they're going to be safe and sound and
protected from all of this stuff
actually you know some of them are
writing to us saying look we love the
show
and my family watch it every sunday on
on our tv but
you know i've lost my job or you know my
hours have been cut or whatever it might
be
so people you know people are being
affected but my broader point is
in this sort of environment uh a lot of
people are gonna suffer and that's
terrible
there will be some people who benefit
and i guess the question for all of us
is
well everything else being the way that
it is
which one of those two do you want to be
yeah very much so man i
i really like the um insight that you've
got that
you lived through a period of change and
chaos and so you
sort of straddled both before during and
after
which again a very very unique view
i've been thinking a lot especially over
the last few months about the fact that
all of the catastrophes that we've had
over the last
80 years since the end of world war ii
really
just have been kind of nerfed versions
of proper problems
you know like the spanish flu serious
serious big pandemic proper existential
[ __ ]
or the world war ii proper serious war
people dying yep iraq big deal desert
storm big deal you know afghanistan big
deal
911 not to be made light of 2008
financial crisis not to be made light of
but all of these versions were these
incidents were dealt with
in ways that were manageable and were
fairly
quickly rebounded from um and
this really is a reminder i think of
just how tenuous
humanity's grasp on existence existences
you know like if
anyone thought like what are some of the
the human institutions that we usually
rely on
finances yeah the banks will look after
it the economy will be
okay health oh well at least grandma and
granddad are all right or at least
there's a future
for my kids education oh well at least
like little timmy can go off to school
all this sort of stuff like there's very
few
areas that haven't been shaken to their
core
and i appreciate both sides of the fence
with people now saying well look the
the lockdowns and stuff there's mental
health problems that are coming through
i'm not convinced that um opening up
fairly ambivalent about the about the
lockdowns it's just kind of i leave it
to the epidemiologists and the
virologists and public health experts
but um i think that the lockdowns are
only a small part of this i think the
ambient anxiety is due to a lot more of
what's going on it's the fact that
everyone has been wildly reminded of
their own mortality and they're staring
it in the face
look at just how we don't like it no we
really don't like it do we
well i mean think of anyone who's read
ernest becker's denial of death
like that is about the fact that
everything we do in life is to escape
our awareness of death and if there's
ever been a year like 2020 is the year
that death is stared all of us in the
face
financial death educational death career
death
uh health scary man it is and
i think as you're pointing i mean i i
share your analysis by the way on the
series of smaller crises we've had since
world war ii the only thing i would
possibly
add for broader pictures of course the
cuban missile crisis which
uh in which we were literally minutes
away from
everyone on the planet dying but you
didn't feel as visceral on an individual
level it wasn't like we were all
you know sitting in our bunkers um but
apart from that i agree with you
but i think in terms of death the thing
that we've seen is
we're so desperate to push [ __ ] out of
our awareness as something that we don't
even
recognize as existing that we're making
very bad decisions because
you know sure we can leave the the
lockdown stuff to the epidemiologist but
but we've interviewed doctors on the
show we've interviewed people
on the show and a lot of people now have
concluded that
the lockdown while not necessarily
preventing many coveted deaths
there's not any particularly strong
evidence that that is the case
is definitely having a huge impact on
the number of deaths we're going to see
in in the months and years to come
because what's happening is
you're saving the lives of elderly
people
who who end up living a few months
longer or a year longer
and the cost of that is that you are
delaying cancer diagnosis you're
delaying
uh other treatments for others very
serious conditions in younger people
uh you're delaying dealing with mental
health exacerbating people's problems
with
many many things and the chances are
more people will die as a result of the
lockdowns
than i've covered 19. can you explain
what weaponizing
empathy means
so this is from an interview i did with
the former deputy prime minister of
australia
uh john anderson and and he was very
kind to have me and i really enjoyed
talking to him
one of the things we were talking about
is how identity politics has been used
uh uh to antagonize different groups
against each other and identity politics
for people who aren't familiar with it
being the idea that the way we should
think of ourselves
in terms of our political discussions
isn't
you know i'm constantine and i'm chris
and i constantine think
this about the economy and i think this
about uh
culture and i think this about
immigration and you have your own
individual thoughts but rather we should
think of it
as well we're two men or i'm an
immigrant and i assume you're
british-born and british descent right
uh i love the confidence with y'all yeah
yeah i'm definitely
i'm from i'm from the north east of
england with
a mum who's like 1 16 scottish and a dad
who's from newton a cliff
i'm like as as born and bred salt of the
earth as you're going to find
right exactly so so so identity politics
basically says that
you should think of yourself as a
straight white man i assume you're
straight i don't know
maybe yeah straight so whatever you are
straight white man uh i am
a straight possibly white man but i'm
also jewish and i'm also an immigrant
and i should think
about myself and my political views
through that prism so let's say that uh
instead of being straight white and male
you were
a black gay woman well your views
wouldn't be dictated by your individual
personality
but rather the views that you have are
shaped primarily by the fact that you
are black that you are gay that you're
female
and that the way you should view
politics is through that prism and the
way that society should view you
is also through that prison in other
words by looking at you
i can already tell that you as a stray
white man massively privileged
been oppressing people for centuries
your people are the evil blah blah blah
blah
and equally if you're a a black gay
woman well the chances are you're super
oppressed
and therefore that means you're supposed
to have certain political views
as well that's identity politics so and
this is
uh a view of politics that has
completely taken over
uh our cultural institutions in society
and many other institutions too
it's the way we talk you know there was
a a liberal mp today or the other day
who suggested that we need
all ethnic minority shortlists right
this is the sort of product
like a team sheet like a roll call
can all of the latinos put their hands
up please
right so saying the way you get mps or
from ethnic minority backgrounds into
parliament is not allow white people to
stand in certain constituents
essentially right
because white people are quote unquote
privileged therefore they don't deserve
that opportunity they've had too many
opportunities already
and we need to raise up people um and of
course what this ignores is
almost exclusively the the ethnic
minority people who do
come in many many cases actually you
know they've been to
a private school went to oxbridge uh
you know did ppe there uh at oxford and
then
became a parliamentary assistant and
work or or in rishi sunax case you know
very prominent family etc um
with links to banking or whatever his
background is right
so it's taking this very blunt force
view
of of racial relations uh of of
relations between men and women and of
how we conduct our politics
now how is that and my point was when i
was talking
about this is how has that happened how
has this
ideology which is antithetical to
everything western society is built on
western society is built on the idea
that we're all individuals
right and and what matters about us is
not the color
of skin i remember a guy called martin
luther something that was talking about
this
right how we should not be judged by our
skin color but rather we should be
judged by the content of our character
by who we are as individuals
how did this collective idea i
identify an idea how did that embed
itself so firmly into our political
discussion and and the way it has is
it's a very powerful tool because if i
say to you well look
excuse me as an immigrant i am deeply
oppressed
or my life has been difficult well
unless you're a psychopath
your instinct is to go oh i'm sorry to
hear that like
what's what's been your life experience
right and that's most people's instinct
because most people are compassionate
and caring
and they want to you know to express
support and sympathy for people who
who are victims of life because some
people genuinely have had difficult
experience that we all have
but some people more than others and so
you take that and you use people's
empathy
against them if you say to people well
look uh
you know britain is the most evil racist
country in the world
a lot of people initially will go well
well okay especially in this country
where the culture is sort of very
apologetic and
you well i'm sorry you know you stepped
on my foot but i apologize to you that
sort of
attitude um people go okay well
you know let's look at maybe maybe you
know did we we had slavery in this
country and
and we we had this and we had that and
you know our ancestors did certain
things
let's maybe look at that you know if
you're saying that you are discriminated
against in modern society because of
your skin color or your
sexuality or or whatever else it might
be well
maybe that's true let's have a look at
that and i think there's definitely some
room for that
you know when i came to this country in
the 90s it was certainly less
tolerant than it is now and i think that
progress has been a result of of
that sort of attitude of like let's make
sure that we learn the lessons from the
stephen lawrence murder and cover up by
the police right
let's learn the lessons from certain
things that have happened that are
atrocious and tragic
let's learn the lessons of you know the
racism that was quite common in this
country 30 40
50 years ago uh but what it's got to now
is the people who've who who create that
sort of grievance industry
some of which was initially needed they
now want to survive and sustain their
lives and so you've got these
professional race-baiters on tv who go
on and talk about
how you know they're even more oppressed
than they've ever been and life is
terrible
and what they're doing is they're using
decent ordinary people's empathy
against them i really like the
weaponizing empathy
terminology i think it it nicely
encapsulates
the weakness that is being targeted
and as someone who does have excess
empathy it makes for a very
difficult um it makes me confused about
my own views because i get scared about
saying the wrong thing
about upsetting someone uh then as
you'll be aware and
uh you know as a little bit of an
insight behind breaking the fourth wall
for how you guys and both me will be
i wonder whether you have felt the
increase in ambient anxiety about saying
the wrong thing is your platform grows
like when it's a full-on bedroom project
that no one gives a [ __ ] about
you're like well so what like i've got
all this other stuff that's going on
but as your baby as a independent
podcaster or broadcaster
or radio host or whatever it might be as
that becomes a bigger and bigger part
part of your life financially um
passionately
career-wise as that grows you're
actually hanging a second
i got something to lose here i genuinely
have something that i should be afraid
of with that you get more stability
because presumably you would have the
support of a larger audience
you also have a greater backlog
of content jordan peterson has always
said um
if you want to call me a right-wing nazi
there is hundreds of hours of me
lecturing online please find the point
at which i've done that
um but yeah have you felt that because i
i certainly
little twinges in the back of my mind
i'm like there's something to lose here
now
yeah i think i've got a very sort of
perverse personality in that way
in that uh i actually feel much freer to
speak my mind
now than than i've ever done because
first of all
i'm very clear that uh not everyone's
gonna agree with me
you know what that contract that we
referenced when i turned it down two
years ago
became a big story and that sort of it
like
broke everything for me like in a moment
you know sometimes you stretch a band
and stretch a band and stretch your band
and eventually
but for me it was just like snapped the
[ __ ] thing straight in literally in
two weeks
baptism yeah baptism of phi exactly so i
went from literally
no one really knows me i don't have any
public profile i'm on
a comedian on the comedy circuit i'm
doing pretty well but not
not anything spectacular i'm moving up
the ranks
i get on with most people very well i
don't
comedians sort of like me other
comedians and my colleagues whatever two
in the space of two weeks going
okay well half of the comedy industry
now hates me
[Laughter]
and from that moment just the number of
[ __ ] i give
has rapidly plummeted towards zero very
very quickly
uh and the thing is the bigger the
platform grows
uh in terms of trigonometry and my own
following
i just feel people have got our backs
man you know the people who watch our
show
they'll back us and if if we come under
attack they will
chip in and they'll help us out and if
if we get sued for something
there'll be people to help us out the
free speech union uh
is a big factor in darren grimes case
but in many others they're helping
people deal with
you know libelous accusations being
sacked for
from work for saying something
controversial whatever
um so i feel like there's there's
actually
you know on trigonometry we probably
have about 200 000 subscribers across
the different platforms if you put
youtube and other stuff together
there's 200 000 people many many of whom
really believe in what we're doing they
they agree with the principle of what
we're doing which is trying to have
honest conversations with interesting
people which is what you do
and if they feel that that is being
destroyed i have every confidence that
uh our audience will back us up and that
you know
we were just chatting today in the
studio with the guys with the team about
you know we posted a joke uh i posted a
joke on
about the the vaccine uh on on my
twitter
being good good with mathematics yeah
about that i basically said that i'm
gonna take
a rushed vaccine i'm not worried about
it because i've always wanted to be good
with mass
uh the idea being that vaccines some
people say give you autism right
and and the first comment on under that
facebook post on our page was
i am autistic and i just like to say i'm
not in any way offended by this book
audience we've built are people who
really appreciate what we do and they'll
back us up
and i hope that's not naive and as long
as we stick to our principles i think
you know people have your back and
that's really the great power of the
internet is in the past i think
canceling people was much easier because
all you did is
you know you burn them at the stake or
you get them fired or whatever it might
have been
now you know for people like me and you
being cancelled may actually be quite
beneficial
clout man everything everything's cl as
my
good friend and social media marketer
buddy johnny says clicks and clicks
and that's the situation you found
yourself in
with the contract you know it's like
yeah it was i think everyone gets
a couple of cracks at like the viral
moment zooby's deadlift video darren
grimes is being called in by the met
police
your contract thing um my early one was
love island but we don't talk about that
um so you know we have these
opportunities to
to to kind of capitalize on it and
you're totally correct that that
first order effect of being a weakness
might second third fourth order effect
actually be the platform the springboard
that you need
to then further the further the audience
so yeah man i hope
i hope that you're right i really do
think decentralizing the control
um and and being your going to great
lengths to make yourself
uncounselable as sam harris says is
strong builder following on a platform
then build an email list that is not
mediated by
anyone try and cancel you like go to
move your platform
move your audience anywhere once you
have an email list they can go
anywhere and that's bulletproof
yeah obviously there are exceptions to
that and some people have been sort of
censored way off but you know
i'm not uh as i sort of joked at the
beginning i'm super controversial
actually i have very centrist opinions
on pretty much everything
um it's just the weird world we live in
so i i don't
ever anticipate you know being taken off
all these platforms for saying what i
say
uh but i'll still you know insist that
other people shouldn't
i love it what is your prediction for
the 2020 election
uh i every day i wake up and i change my
mind
what's today then today is friday the
16th of october 2020.
what's your prediction yes so yesterday
i thought biden
today i think trump is going to win but
it's going to be close and it's going to
get very messy
take me through the thinking
okay so national polling uh and i i
invite people
they is how soon after we record this is
this going out
less than a week so pretty quick okay so
our interview with a guy called jim
rickards who was one of the analysts who
predicted
trump's first election uh very early on
uh we'll be going out at some point in
the next week or two after this goes out
and uh we've had him on the show a
number of times
and what he was saying was yes that
biden is up in the national polls by 10
to 12 points
he is but national polls don't matter
because in america they don't have
national elections
right it's all done state by state so
you have to win
the battleground states uh the fact that
uh
biden and harris are gonna get let's say
four million more votes in california
than trump doesn't really matter because
you don't win california
once so the national polling isn't
necessarily indicative of the result if
you remember in 2016
hillary won the popular vote by quite
some margin didn't really help her
because of the electoral college
so that's not well that's one part of it
obviously the shy trump voter
is a huge phenomenon right and also i
think
it's not been much covered in in the
mainstream media uh
in this country or much of the
mainstream media in america but what is
happening in many cities
or several cities in america now is
full-blown riots
burning down of property shops people
are being killed in the streets for
you know turning up to some protests and
being pro-trump literally being shot in
the head et cetera et cetera
and uh the antifa people who are doing
this are now taking that
fight to the suburbs they're taking it
into where
the middle class kuan koi people live
and
i can tell you one thing that i know
from experience
the moment you start messing with
people's sense of safety
the moment a middle-class couple with
two children
and nice car and a garage or whatever
suddenly feel like there's
armed people outside who may well burn
their house down
that is the moment when people will vote
for anyone
as long as they promise to prevent that
which is my greatest fear with all of
this
right and i don't know if you remember
when we had the blm riots in london
i had a massive super viral thread on
twitter talking about
this very thing that the greatest danger
of allowing these riots to happen and
then
being biased in terms of saying they're
largely peaceful when police officers
are being attacked et cetera
is that if you show people these scenes
of disorder long enough
and they should show the police backing
down and not tackling and not undressing
the sort of
disorder then what they will eventually
go is look
i don't care what this guy i don't care
if he's racist
i don't care if he wants to deport
immigrants i just care
that he or she is going to deliver
stability
and order and my
sense is that there will be many people
in america
who don't want to see their cities
burned down who are going to look at
what's happening and go
look i don't like donald trump i think
he may be a bit racist
i think he shouldn't talk about women
the way he talks
i think he's obnoxious i think he's
brash but they're going to look at that
and go
what what's the choice here i can either
have a racist sex as president
if that's how they see it or i can have
my house burned down now you put that in
front of any certain person
right that's that that's what i see
so i i've sort of been disenthralled of
this idea that the national polls are
are necessarily a strong predictor it's
going to be close
and it's probably going to end up uh not
being
uh a result on election night we may not
see a result
during which time donald trump is almost
certainly going to be
the leader because republicans tend to
vote in person democrats much more
uh with the voting uh do the voting via
post
so what you're gonna have is a week or
two when
donald trump quote unquote won but the
election result isn't unconfirmed
and then those ballots may come in and
he may then
lose that's not a healthy situation my
friend
um i'm glad you know one of my biggest
criticisms of trump is that he refused
to say that he would hand over power
peacefully
uh until yesterday which is when he
finally did which i'm glad
uh because i think you know that's
completely unacceptable in a democracy
for one party to say they wouldn't
accept the result of an election on the
other hand
it's equally deeply unacceptable for
biden to refuse to talk about whether
he's gonna pack
the court or not because if you start
messing with the
supreme court and the number of justices
on that to suit your political agenda
well that's the end of the american
project as well
uh so both of those things are
completely unacceptable i'm glad trump
has wrote back on that i hope
biden uh and kamala harris now say
they're not gonna do that as well
because
uh that is very very important but it's
going to get messy
it is douglas i asked douglas the same
question this has been a theme i asked
god sad i asked
andrew doyle i was talking about
yourself uh and
douglas gave the most he had to pull the
fence out of his ass
in order to be able to uh actually speak
but he said
um whatever happens it's not going to be
very well accepted and he's got some
quite big fears which is interesting
because he's now in america
like he's now over there so like fair
play mate
like if stuff gets set on fire you've
decided to pop yourself in amongst it
um yeah i agree i think that no matter
your political leaning
trying to undermine the democratic
process at large
really has to be one of those things
that's unacceptable it's like look
you can two foot slide tackle me i can
push you while you're off the ball
but no one can come in and pick it up
and run away or shoot the referee
like these things are outside the rules
of the game in fact they changed the
rules of the game
if we're supposed to be playing chess
and you rugby tackle me to the floor
like that kind of just what what are we
what are we doing here there has to be
some upper bound but again like what
have we been this
disintegrationist left as ben shapiro
and
dave rubin refer to it like
that game of one upsmanship
will do something will break some rules
so we'll break some rules so we'll break
some rules
and think as well everybody's
self-branding everyone looks
in some form or another for some reason
there is a particular
minority who look to political leaders
as examples as role models of how they
should
like spend their lives morally or just
you know trump says something then you
get it regurgitated
or biden says something then kamala
harris says something they get
regurgitated
like if they are saying well we can
break all of the rules and they're
supposed to be these
paragons of diplomatic virtue right
they're supposed to be the ones who are
the least uh um at the mercy of trance
as you know the [ __ ] lighthouse in
the storm type [ __ ] that's what your
politicians are supposed to be
um if they're prepared to keep on
changing all of the rules
what precedent does that set for
everybody else and it really
it really can quite quickly become a
vicious cycle so yeah i think
um the next when is the is it the 22nd
of november when is it
the third of november oh [ __ ] it's very
simple it's soon man
wow so i mean the next three weeks
are going to be they're going to be
compelling well let me
be compelling if you like horror movies
there is another aspect to this and i
think you speak to that very well which
is that
uh if you allow politicians to to
conduct themselves in this way
and to delegitimize the democratic
process which both
sides have done but particularly in my
opinion the democrats
uh in america and the left in this
country as well uh
then what you end up with is a situation
where we are now where 36
of both democrats and republicans feel
uh that violence is justified to achieve
your political ends
so a third of both supporter groups are
quite happy to use violence
right which has gone up from eight
percent about two years ago
so if you've got that situation the
election is in dispute both parties are
undermining
the the democratic process and
encouraging their followers
uh essentially to feel like violence is
a way of resolving this issue
not a good recipe not a good recipe
not at all and i think you know to see
we we often
see these tip of the spear moments that
um
they're like the maxim pithy aphorism
quote that everyone remembers that tells
them about what a wider concept means
and some of the things that we've seen
like trump not
being presidential during the debate
like
perhaps four years ago it was cool and
quirky and
new and made people feel like he was
going to drain the swamp and do this
cool thing and
oh isn't it interesting to see someone
who's not diplomatic and doesn't play by
the rules
whereas now you're like yeah okay mate
like this is
this is kind of old hat now i'm not so
fussed about i just want to hear the
debate let's get back to
that rule and that you know we vacillate
between two different extremes
and finally find something somewhere in
the middle but then you've got it on the
left as well with the way
it's much more of a uh how would you say
it's the the sneaky [ __ ] game that's
being played on the left it's the brash
hit it with a mallet game that's being
played by trump
um but yeah man i i'm gonna be like you
say compelled for the horror movie
over the uh over the next couple of
months couple of questions left
um why are comedians getting involved
in political dialogue like people might
not have expected
individuals like you and andrew doyle
would have been the vanguard of free
speech
well for comedians it's something that
we feel viscerally because every time
you go on stage
you are already self-censoring uh
because you're trying to find
that point between what you are saying
and what the audience wants to hear and
you're trying to find that line right so
we're constantly playing with it
and of course we say things that we
don't mean
right so this literalism the idea that
we should take jokes literally
and if you if i made a joke about
autistic people
that means i hate autistic people right
that is a problem for us on a sort of
practical level if you like
uh i also think comedy attracts people
who are rebels by nature
and so we're naturally drawn to or at
least that's what i thought until i
went into the comedy industry and found
it to be the most conformist
uh monarch mono culture i've ever seen
uh but i did think you know watching
uh you know people like bill hicks and
george carlin and and people like that
that you know comedies for for people
who like have a different opinion man
and that they
you know they want to say something that
some people don't want to hear
right like that's what i thought but now
apparently that's not what comedy is
about comedy is about
making sure that you you make fun of the
right people uh
and uh you know make you whatever this
workshop is i can't even be bothered to
talk about it anymore
um so i think comedians are naturally
sort of
rebellious by nature at least some of us
are so
it's a sort of professional hazard to us
uh the restriction of free speech and
there's also the other thing of like we
don't like restrictions we are
pro-freedom and restricting people's
speech restricts how they think and
jordan peterson hammered this
point home a lot which is without being
able to speak freely you can't think
freely
um and if you can't think freely well
we're all [ __ ] so i think
that's that's kind of where it's coming
from uh comedians the saviors that we
need at the moment you reckon more
comedians
uh i don't know i i think i think it
takes everybody look i mean i think look
look at the free speech union which i've
mentioned they're doing great work
shows like that yours and ours uh you
know we're not strictly comedians
in in this context but we're doing what
i think is good work
uh there are some journalists who are
starting to push bank against all of
this stuff
uh i i think everybody's got a hand in
this i think the main thing is
uh the people need to to think about do
you want to live in in a society that
judges everybody by their skin color
their race their sexuality their gender
etc
or do you want to live in a society that
we all remember that we're individuals
and we come together based on
what we think how we feel about things
what are what are our views
and if we want to sort of divide
ourselves
ourselves up which we'll always will do
because we're tribal by nature
then the healthy way to do that is is to
sort of do it on a voluntary basis of
well i think this and you think that and
we both believe in free speech so let's
form a free speech society or whatever
else it might be as opposed to going
well
we're both men men need to stick
together
you know yeah well i mean we do uh which
guest have you enjoyed most or been most
surprised by this year
i don't know i i always hesitate to
answer this question because it's like
saying you know
my one of my heroes michael jordan
basketball player was once asked which
of his six
championship titles uh was his favorite
and he said well that's like asking me
which which of my kin kids i love the
most right
so to me you know obviously we have
brilliant guests and some guests some
stronger than others or whatever uh but
uh i try not to sort of evaluate it that
way we've had so many brilliant guests
which one which one were you most most
surprised by was the one that
you particularly were um pleasantly
surprised by
well i actually would say darren grimes
i mean he comes across
as incredibly intelligent articular
uh interesting uh original thoughtful
uh not in any way sort of unpleasant or
you know controversial even the guy is
pretty you know he has the views of half
the country on
pretty much every issue uh so so i was
surprised at that because i didn't
really i wasn't all that familiar with
him
i knew him as the right wing commentator
you know
uh and so yeah i mean that's the one
that comes to mind straight away it's
just he was
you know we were both very very
impressed with darren yeah he
for someone who has that accent i love
the fact that he's so erudite
and yet we'll say like off to me moms to
go and get myself some fish and chips
like how is this there's some bizarre
world
because it's so london centric right
especially the publishing in the
uk um to hear someone who for me is a
very very familiar accent
um deploying some incredibly complex and
nuanced
thoughts i'm like yeah yeah that's
that's cool man
last question what is the one thing that
we're not talking about that we really
should be
ah shoes on the other foot now
how's that for you and unlike us you
didn't warn me this was coming
um i think the one thing we're not
talking about is
the end game of all of this
the end game of identity politics what
is
that if you mult if you play the movie
forward
where do you get to and i think if more
of us thought about that
and were prepared to speak about that
openly and more people considered those
outcomes
we would be much more careful and much
more reluctant to proceed
in the direction that we've been going
because the truth is that
they tried it with men and women they
tried to antagonize women against men
and they they managed to some extent
but no matter how hard you try those as
somebody said i can't remember who this
too much fraternizing with the enemy
between men and women so you can't quite
drive them apart deep down
even if you teach one young woman at
university that all men are bad all men
are evil whatever
eventually the biology kicks in and they
go i want a partner i want to have
children i want this i want that not all
of them but many will do
so you can't really drive them apart but
the racial issue is very different
there it's it's not written anywhere in
stone on a tablet that moses brought
down from the mountain
that we have to have a multi-ethnic
society
it's not written anywhere that is an
experiment
that we've willingly engaged in and
suspended our human tribalism
to actually try to make it happen and
we've said
look the american dream is right we
don't have a british dream but in
america
if you come to this country right and
you work hard you get your head down you
learn the language you integrate
you are american if you come to britain
and you settle down here you make a
route you learn the language you
integrate you become part of society you
drink tea and apologize and whatever
else you're supposed to do
right you are british
that's what we've said and that is an
experiment that was working
and working very well and getting better
and better and better
now if you look across the world that's
not how most countries are most
countries are essentially ethno-states
right now we've said we're going to have
a multi-ethnic society well the only way
a multi-ethnic society works
the only way a multi-ethnic society
remains peaceful
the only way a multi-ethnic society
remains coherent
is if people set aside their racial
categories
and actually don't say well i'm a black
person or i am a brown person i'm a
white person no you say i'm british
right that's not to say you have to
discard your black or white or whatever
identity but
you can't be the first thing that you
think of when you think about yourself
because otherwise you're driving people
apart and the end game of that
is very very ugly man that is a an
apocalyptic answer but one that i agree
with i said this to andrew when he came
on the show the other day that
the hopeful counter to this i'll give
you
my thesis for us moving forward or my
hope
i would guess is that
in the same way that the pandemic has
been quite
pissed weak i know it's done a lot of
damage but really covered it just
doesn't have the mortality that it needs
to cause a real existential threat now
it still might mutate and all that stuff
like disclaimer disclaimer
um but it was quite a weak version of it
and yet we were wholly unprepared for it
but if and when a new pandemic comes
around that's got smallpox level
mortality
we understand how to lock down more
effectively we understand how it shut
travel routes we can get
ppe produced more quickly we've got the
3d printing we've got the
the ventilators we've got all that stuff
right so we are prepared because we
would delivered a kind of a weak dose of
something that may be worse in the
future
my hope is that the identity politics
game which is being promulgated over the
last few years
that has attached itself to the wrong
horse the trojan horse that it's tried
to deliver a particular ideology in
is inherently so self-contradictory and
just a losing race that everyone can see
the hypocrisy in it
the ridiculousness of it and it's so
self-defeating because it fractures
its own group into competing
different levels of hierarchy to the
point in which the snake just eats its
own tail
and in future if some other ideologues
decide to come along
and get themselves behind a particular
cause that we got hang on a second
like i remember that you played this
game once before like we've been here
now this one might seem a little bit
more seductive or more polished and a
bit more
virtuous truthful whatever but no no
no no we we had this so i'm wondering
whether or not
this ridiculous example of trying to
push
a particular ideology has been attached
to the wrong
the wrong racehorse and is potentially
going to
inoculate us against it happening in
future
it's a very optimistic view one that i
shared in march
uh i thought that in march we had about
a month uh
up until about dominic cummings
and then immediately after george floyd
there was that moment
we had an opportunity you know we all
quote unquote came together
shared humanity shared humanity clapped
for the nhs
etc etc and even then some people tried
to go on about how
you know uh bain people are more likely
to die from covet and somehow
that's society's fault when in fact it's
just the vitamin d
is harder to obtain for people with
darker skin
but but it was sort of ignored mostly
and we sort of pulled together
but i think the lockdown the impact of
people spending more time on social
media
worrying about the future being stuck
indoors many people
in you know if you if you are living in
a happy family
and you work from home and you you know
uh you've got a garden and a a nice
house
uh then your mental health's probably
fine uh if your job is safe and all the
rest of it but for a lot of people it
wasn't like that
i know people young people who for
example you know they were stuck
with uh somebody else in the house a
step parent who was abusive
you know uh or or just people stuck
in the wrong environment with flatmates
that they've meaning they've been
meaning to leave that flat and they were
in dispute or
people stuck in in loveless marriages or
whatever that
mental health impact i think is what
then exploded
with blm that pent up frustration
anger confusion that's why we had
protests about george floyd in the uk
which if you think about it
doesn't really make much sense man i
agree
constantine thank you so much for today
people want to check out trigonometry or
yourself where should they go where do
they
where do they direct themselves i am on
twitter at constantin kissing and the
show is at
trigger pod we're on youtube all the
podcast apps just search for
trigonometry
as in gun trigger t-r-i-g-e-r
amazing man if i get a call off the mets
police we can share an uber there
together uh hopefully we haven't crossed
any boundaries i i've really really
enjoyed today i think that you guys are
doing fantastic work
um i'm proud to be of the
the particular little sort of weird
[ __ ] up community that we've got of
british podcasters
doing good work at the moment so long
may it continue
thanks i appreciate it and and right
back at you and also
if we do have to share an uber that
would be illegal because we need to
socialize
thank you man
you